would you rather have the ability to be
invisible or have a clone of yourself to
go to work when you're hungover
clone of myself dude because then it'd
just be like man imagine those fights
when you're really having some
self-loathing you're like clone and he
gets out and you're like put him up
put them up I just remembered something
you said drunk to a friend and I'm
embarrassed by it Wham I would do every
every night at my house would be like
the ending of Rocky III you know where
I'd be sitting there and I'd be like you
want to ring the bell or you want me my
clones like thing
that's ever none of my house all right
who's that news is you want to ring the
bell you want me around
[Applause]
me and my clothes connecting oh man I
love if someone could do that painting
with me and myself in that Old Rocky 3
Style
I'm way on board of that clone me up